From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Tobin Low, in for Ira Glass. You may have heard of comedian Tig Notaro, but if you're a gay person like me, you have really heard of Tig Notaro. She is what I would call gay famous, which makes the story of what happened to her so surprising. She and her wife, Stephanie, have two kids, twin boys.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》。我是托宾·洛，代班艾拉·格拉斯。你们可能听说过喜剧演员蒂格·诺塔罗，但如果你们像我一样是同性恋，那你肯定听说过蒂格·诺塔罗。我称她为“同性恋圈的名人”，这使得发生在她身上的故事格外令人惊讶。她和她的妻子斯蒂芬妮有两个孩子，一对双胞胎男孩。
And after seven years of living in the same house with Stephanie and Tig, having their two moms tend to every meal and butt wipe, seven years of the boys telling their teachers and random whoevers that they have two moms, they're all in the car on the way to first grade one morning.
和斯蒂芬妮以及蒂格在同一个屋檐下生活了七年，由两位妈妈照顾每一顿饭和擦屁股，七年来孩子们一直告诉老师和随便哪个路人他们有两个妈妈，一天早上，他们全家正开车去上一年级的路上。
Stephanie and I were just in the front seat talking, and they were in the back seat talking, like we always do. And then Stephanie said something about us being gay. And our son, Finn, leans forward and pokes his head between us, and he says, you're gay?
我和斯蒂芬妮在前面座位聊天，他们在后座说话，就像我们平时那样。然后斯蒂芬妮提到了我们是同性恋的事。我们的儿子芬恩向前探过身，把头伸进我们中间，他说，你们是同性恋？
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
We were obviously just as shocked as he was. We were like, uh, yeah. And he said, what's "gay"? And that was a whole other level of stunned. Oh, my gosh. How is this information only just now coming out?
我们显然和他一样震惊。我们说，呃，是的。他说，什么是“同性恋”？那又是另一种程度的震惊了。天哪。怎么现在才冒出这个信息？
Tig's been with her wife for over a decade. And as far as they knew, they've been gay for the entirety of their children's lives. But apparently, it was news to Max and Finn.
蒂格和她的妻子在一起已经超过十年了。就她们所知，在孩子们出生的整个过程里，她们一直是同性恋。但显然，这对马克斯和芬恩来说是个新闻。
Then I started to feel insecure, thinking, oh, my gosh, here he's lived over seven years not knowing he had gay parents. What if he's upset now? What if he doesn't like his life or his family, or he's disappointed in some way, or--
然后我开始感到不安，心想，天哪，他在这七年多的时间里竟然不知道自己有两个同性恋父母。万一他现在很难过怎么办？万一他不喜欢他的生活或家庭，或者以某种方式感到失望，或者——
What's the first thing you say back to him when he asked that question?
当他问出那个问题时，你回应他的第一句话是什么？
I was saying, OK, so gay is when a boy likes a boy, or a girl likes a girl. And that would be specific to being gay.
我说，好吧，同性恋就是男孩喜欢男孩，或者女孩喜欢女孩。这正是同性恋的具体含义。
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
嗯哼，嗯哼。
And they were just like, oh, OK.
他们只是说，哦，好吧。
Before Tig can say more, they're pulling up in front of the school. The car ride is only a couple minutes long. And then the kids are running out of the car, and Tig and her wife are left to wonder how their sons had possibly not seen something right in front of their faces.
在蒂格说更多话之前，车子已经开到了学校门口。车程只有几分钟。然后孩子们跑出了车，蒂格和她的妻子只能纳闷，为什么儿子们竟然没看出来近在眼前的真相。
And we drove away, maybe going half a mile an hour. We were so stunned. Stephanie and I glanced at each other like, what in the hell just happened?
我们开车离开，速度大概只有每小时半英里。我们太震惊了。我和斯蒂芬妮面面相觑，心想，这到底发生了什么鬼？
Do you have a moment after this comes out where you're like, oh, no, what kind of parent am I that this hasn't been discussed? Is there a part of your brain doing that?
这件事曝光后，你是否有过那么一刻心想，天哪，我算什么家长，这事居然都没讨论过？你脑子里有这样的想法吗？
Oh, a million percent. I mean, [LAUGHS] when there's any sort of moment-- I was going to say "moment like this," but I don't know how many moments like this I've had. I mean, I did have a similar one when they were five and I was reading them a story before bed. And Finn interrupted me and said-- they call me Mare, which is for "mother," French.
哦，百分之百。我是说，[笑声]当有任何类似的时刻——我本想说“像这样的时刻”，但我不知道我经历过多少次这样的时刻。我是说，当他们五岁时，我在睡前给他们读故事，我也经历过类似的事。芬恩打断我说——他们叫我“Mare”，这是法语中“母亲”的意思。
And Finn said, Mare, are you a boy or a girl? And that was when he was five. And I just stopped, and I laughed. And I said, well, what do you think I am? And he said, I think you're a boy. And I said, OK. I said, well, I am a girl. And he said, huh, OK. But you look like a boy, right? And I said, yeah, yeah. And then we just kept reading the book. And I was just laughing to myself like, oh, my gosh, my son didn't know I was a girl.
芬恩说，Mare，你是男孩还是女孩？那是他五岁的时候。我停下来笑了。我说，好吧，你觉得我是什么？他说，我觉得你是男孩。我说，好吧。我说，嗯，我是个女孩。他说，哈，好吧。但你看上去像个男孩，对吧？我说，是啊，是啊。然后我们就继续读书了。我当时只是在心里偷笑，天哪，我儿子竟然不知道我是个女孩。
One reason all of this was especially mystifying was that the boys, like I said, definitely knew they had two moms, were kind of proud of it.
这一切之所以特别令人费解的一个原因是，正如我所说，孩子们确实知道他们有两个妈妈，而且还引以为豪。
Not like in a, "Oh, yeah, we have two moms." They're just like, "We have two moms. We have two." Also, the school they go to is very progressive and celebrates pride every year. And everyone drops their kids off in rainbows. And--
不是那种“哦，是的，我们有两个妈妈”的语气。他们只是说，“我们有两个妈妈。我们有两个。”此外，他们上的学校非常进步，每年都会庆祝骄傲月。每个人送孩子上学时都带着彩虹标志。而且——
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
And it's like, I guess they didn't know what the pride was. They're just running around with rainbows on them. They're like, sure, Happy Pride.
就像是，我想他们根本不知道骄傲月是什么。他们只是带着彩虹跑来跑去。他们会说，当然，骄傲月快乐。
Tig and Stephanie eventually figured out what happened. Sure, Max and Finn knew they had two moms. But Tig and Stephanie had never sat down with them to say, two moms who are married, that's what gay is. And more importantly, they never said the words, "We're gay."
蒂格和斯蒂芬妮最终弄清了是怎么回事。当然，马克斯和芬恩知道他们有两个妈妈。但蒂格和斯蒂芬妮从未坐下来跟他们说，两个已婚的妈妈，这就是同性恋。更重要的是，她们从没说过“我们是同性恋”这几个字。
It took a while for me to sort that out and understand that a wedding picture and two moms doesn't equal gay.
我花了一段时间才理清思绪，明白结婚照和两个妈妈并不等同于同性恋。
Right, right. And I was thinking about how when you first come out, there's a moment where you have to do this spiel a bunch to people. And then it sort of tapers off, and you just start living your life. Like, I can't remember the last time I had to sit down and have a coming out conversation with somebody.
对，对。我在想，当你刚出柜时，总有一段时间你得不断跟人重复那套说辞。然后它就会慢慢减少，你就开始过自己的生活了。比如，我不记得上次是什么时候需要坐下来跟某人进行出柜谈话了。
Exactly. It has been so long since I had to come out to anybody. Anybody.
正是如此。我已经太久没需要向任何人出柜了。任何人。
Right.
没错。
And I would never have guessed in my own house, there were two people--
而且我永远不会想到，在我自己的家里，竟然有两个人——
Right. [LAUGHS]
对。[笑声]
--that didn't-- we have three cats. I feel like they probably know we're gay.
——不知道——我们有三只猫。我觉得它们可能都知道我们是同性恋。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
This stuff happens all the time. The people close to you miss something about you that seems so obvious. The truth is right in front of their face, and they don't see it.
这种事经常发生。你身边的人会错过关于你的一些看起来如此明显的事情。事实就摆在他们面前，但他们就是看不见。
Today on the show, we have stories of people trying to end this misunderstanding once and for all. In one, they build an actual machine to try to convince the other person. In another, they call a scientist for help. One person even tries reaching out to the federal government, which kind of works. Actually, in every case, they get a certain kind of satisfaction. Stay with us.
今天在节目中，我们将讲述人们试图彻底终结这种误解的故事。在其中一个故事里，他们建造了一台机器试图说服对方。在另一个故事里，他们打电话向科学家求助。甚至有人尝试联系联邦政府，结果还挺管用。实际上，在每种情况下，他们都获得了一种满足感。请留在我们身边。
It's This American Life. Act One, "There Will Be Blood." OK, so in this first story, a person gets so fed up with other people dismissing a thing that was happening to them that they devise a way for the other person to actually experience it firsthand. They build a machine that simulates period pain.
这里是《美国生活》。第一幕，“血将流”。好吧，在第一个故事里，一个人因为受够了别人对发生在他们身上的事情的漠视，设计了一种方法让对方亲身体验。他们建造了一台模拟经痛的机器。
Maybe you've seen these videos on TikTok of people, mostly men, getting hooked up to one of these things, getting to feel for the first time what a person with a uterus goes through regularly. Aviva DeKornfeld, one of the producers on our show, got curious if this social experiment really changes anything, if men who didn't really believe their partners about what happened during their periods would be convinced by this experience.
也许你在TikTok上看过这些视频，大多是男性被连接到这些装置上，第一次感受到子宫拥有者经常经历的事情。我们节目的制片人之一阿维娃·德科恩费尔德感到好奇，这种社会实验是否真的能改变什么，那些不相信伴侣经期经历的男性是否会因为这次体验而被说服。
So she went to see it in the wild at a rodeo in Calgary known as The Stampede, where the machine was set up for anyone who might be a doubter. Here's Aviva.
所以她去卡尔加里的牛仔竞技节“牛仔节”现场看了看，那里的机器是为任何怀疑者准备的。这是阿维娃带来的报道。
I'll admit, I came into this pretty skeptical. The idea that five minutes of manufactured cramping could somehow make men understand women better, it seemed optimistic, especially when their starting point seemed to be so basic. I asked men standing in line for the machine the question, what does a period cramp feel like? Their guesses included food poisoning, bone pain, getting kicked in the balls, a pinch, and being really full.
我承认，我对此持怀疑态度。认为五分钟的模拟抽搐就能让男人更好地理解女性，这似乎太乐观了，尤其是当他们的认知起点看起来如此基础时。我问排队等候使用机器的男人们，经痛是什么感觉？他们的猜测包括食物中毒、骨头疼痛、被踢到蛋蛋、被掐了一下，以及吃得太撑。
More often than not, they made these guesses while standing next to their partner, who was off mic, silently shaking her head no. Either more women than I thought avoid talking about their periods with their partners, or most of these boyfriends have extremely selective hearing.
更多时候，他们是在伴侣身边做出这些猜测的，而伴侣在麦克风外默默摇头。要么是女性比我想象中更少与伴侣谈论她们的经期，要么是这些男朋友有极其选择性的听力。
How is your period pain?
你的经痛怎么样？
Really bad.
非常严重。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
I didn't know they hurt. What? [LAUGHS]
我不知道它们会痛。什么？[笑声]
You didn't know?
你不知道？
No.
不知道。
You're learning right now that your girlfriend has terrible period pain?
你现在才知道你女朋友有严重的经痛吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
How long have you been together?
你们在一起多久了？
Five years.
五年。
His girlfriend asks, what did you think was going on when I was in bed?
他的女朋友问道，当我躺在床上时你以为发生了什么？
I don't know. I thought you just wanted to sleep.
不知道。我以为你只是想睡觉。
Once a month?
每个月一次？
Yeah. I knew it happened. I never really asked much about it.
对。我知道这会发生。我从没怎么问过这件事。
This kind of ignorance is the exact motivation for Lux Perry, the person running the simulator. Lux is 31. They're sharp and funny. They first started running the simulator a couple of years ago and have since taken it all over the world.
这种无知正是模拟器运营者卢克斯·佩里的动力。卢克斯今年31岁，既敏锐又风趣。他们几年前首次开始运行这个模拟器，并自那以后将其带往世界各地。
Lux is doing all of this because period pain has been the defining factor of their life. They have severe endometriosis, which is a chronic disease where tissue that's supposed to grow inside the uterus grows outside of it, which causes all sorts of problems, including extreme pain. Lux has been to the hospital with complications over 75 times, and it took over 20 years for them to even get a diagnosis.
卢克斯做这一切是因为经痛一直是他们生命中的决定性因素。他们患有严重的子宫内膜异位症，这是一种慢性病，即本应在子宫内生长的组织在子宫外生长，这会导致各种问题，包括极度疼痛。卢克斯因并发症住院超过75次，他们花了20多年才得到确诊。
And when, A, everyone around you is telling you that the pain that you experience is completely not real, and it's ruined your entire life, it's kind of how you end up building a simulator. [LAUGHS]
当你周围的所有人都告诉你，你经历的痛苦完全不是真实的，而它却毁了你的整个人生，这就是你最终建造模拟器的原因。[笑声]
Lux isn't the only one who's done this. There are lots of period simulator videos online. But the machine people are using in those other videos only triggers a very superficial cramp, nothing like a real period. Whereas Lux had their machine modified to make the cramps more intense, with the goal of getting people to understand what period pain actually feels like.
卢克斯并不是唯一这样做的人。网上有很多经期模拟器视频。但其他视频中人们使用的机器只触发一种非常表面的抽搐，根本不像真正的经期。而卢克斯修改了他们的机器，使抽搐更剧烈，目的是让人们理解经痛真实的感受。
So you're going to peel them off this plastic thing. And you're going to apply them directly to your skin where your ovaries would be. So--
所以你得把它们从这个塑料片上撕下来。然后把它们直接贴在你的皮肤上，卵巢所在的位置。所以——
The way Lux's machine works, you place two sticky pads where your ovaries are or would be, which is lower than you think.
卢克斯机器的工作方式是，你将两个粘性垫贴在你的卵巢所在的位置，比你想象的要低。
So you want to put them as close together as possible.
所以你要尽可能把它们贴在一起。
Those pads are connected by wires to a handheld machine, which then triggers a cramp. The machine goes from 1 to 10. Lux says most women who have tried the machine say their normal period pain is around level 7, some a little lower, some much, much higher.
这些贴片通过电线连接到一个手持机器上，然后触发抽搐。机器分1到10级。卢克斯说，大多数尝试过该机器的女性表示，她们正常的经痛大约在7级，有些人低一些，有些人则高得多。
I watched 100 people get hooked up to the machine over the course of two days. When Lux cranks the simulator up, women tend to be stoic. They calmly describe the pain they're feeling. I watched one woman on a level 10 say thoughtfully, huh, this is what it felt like when my cyst ruptured. Whereas men tend to sound more like this--
在两天的时间里，我看着100个人被连接到这台机器上。当卢克斯调高模拟器时，女性倾向于坚忍。她们平静地描述着感受到的痛苦。我看着一位女性在10级时深思熟虑地说，嗯，这跟我囊肿破裂时的感觉一样。而男性听起来往往更像是这样——
Oh, my god. Jesus Christ. OK, enough. Enough. Fuck me. Oh, my god. Fuck. Sorry. I'm sorry that happens to you.
哦，我的上帝。耶稣基督。好了，够了。够了。操。哦，我的上帝。操。抱歉。我很抱歉这发生在你身上。
Whenever a guy was hooked up to the machine, women would crowd around the booth to watch. They would shout questions at the man. Would you still be able to go to work? Go out with friends?
每当一个男人被连接到机器上时，女性就会围在摊位前观看。她们会向男人大喊问题。你还能去上班吗？能和朋友出去吗？
Having that pain, would you go to the gym?
经历那种痛苦，你还会去健身房吗？
Oh, no, no. I wouldn't want to. I mean, I probably could, but it wouldn't be a good day.
哦，不，不。我不想去。我是说，我可能做得到，但这不会是好过的一天。
Another woman jumps in.
另一位女性插话。
I have to pick up kids all day. Would you think you could do that?
我得整天抱孩子。你觉得你能做到吗？
Probably not. I don't know. It wouldn't be fun for sure. I'd probably just want to sit, watch TV, and not really do much.
大概不能。我不知道。那肯定不好玩。我可能只想坐着，看电视，不干什么事。
The women badgered and heckled from the sidelines, good-naturedly, but still, oftentimes, they would lament to one another that the simulator could only simulate cramps, wishing it could somehow also trigger the headaches, back pain, hormones, acne, nausea, depression, and everything else that comes with menstruation. There seemed to be a real pleasure in watching the men writhe. A tiny bit of justice, if only for a minute.
女性们在场边戏谑、嘲讽，虽然是善意的，但她们仍然经常向彼此抱怨，模拟器只能模拟抽搐，希望它能以某种方式同时触发月经带来的头痛、背痛、激素变化、痤疮、恶心、抑郁以及其他一切。看着男人们扭动身体似乎有一种真正的快感。哪怕只有一分钟，也算是一种小小的正义。
Let me just say, I know how all this sounds so binary. I don't mean to drag us back to a time when we thought of men and women as two totally different species. And I'm not saying all men acted this way, and all women acted this other way. There are obviously exceptions, though, honestly, as far as I saw, not many.
让我声明一下，我知道这一切听起来很二元。我无意把我们带回那种认为男人和女人是完全不同物种的时代。我并不是说所有的男人都表现得这样，而所有的女人都表现得那样。当然有例外，不过老实说，据我所见，并不多。
To be clear, most of the men I met were nice, empathetic. They clearly knew what they were supposed to say. Of course, they believe women, even if other feelings slip out sometimes.
明确地说，我遇到的大多数男人都很友善、善解人意。他们显然知道自己该说什么。当然，他们相信女性，即使有时会流露出其他感受。
Why do you think your girlfriend wants you to do this?
你觉得你女朋友为什么想让你做这个？
I don't know how it feels. So she always whines about it. So I got to test it out and see what she's whining about. [LAUGHS]
我不知道那是什么感觉。所以她总是为此发牢骚。所以我得亲自测试一下，看看她到底在发什么牢骚。[笑声]
Does "whine" feel like the right verb to you?
“发牢骚”这个词对你来说合适吗？
No. No. They actually hurt. Just wait. Wait till you see--
不。不。它们真的很痛。等着吧。等你看过就知道了——
At least half the men who tried the simulator did so because their girlfriend or wife was dragging them, sometimes literally, over to the booth and forcing them to try it. And Lux would have a number of couples storm off afterwards. They like to guess which couples are going to break up.
至少有一半尝试模拟器的男性是因为女朋友或妻子拖着，有时甚至是硬拽着他们过去并强迫他们尝试的。卢克斯在那之后见过不少情侣愤然离去。他们喜欢猜测哪对情侣会分手。
Yeah, we had this couple last year. They were young-ish, maybe in their mid 20s. And she really wanted him to experience it because she had endo.
是啊，去年我们见过一对情侣。他们比较年轻，大概20多岁。她真的很想让他体验一下，因为她患有子宫内膜异位症。
Endo, short for endometriosis.
内异症，子宫内膜异位症的缩写。
He was completely dismissive leading up to. And then when he was on the simulator, he, like, pushed through it. You can see when people are really trying to suppress the experience. And so he was really like, wouldn't say that he was in pain, and they stormed off completely pissed at each other. She was like, why would you-- why do you have to say all those things in front of people? We could hear her.
他一直表现得很不屑。当他在模拟器上时，他硬撑着。你可以看出什么时候人们是真的在抑制这种体验。所以他真的表现得很——不愿说自己很痛苦，他们彻底吵着架离开了。她说，为什么你要那样——你为什么要在别人面前说那些话？我们都能听到。
What was he saying?
他在说什么？
Well, he was saying that she exaggerates, that it's not that bad, like that if this is what you're going through, there's no reason that you can't do the dishes, or it was, like, really offensive stuff. And it's just, sometimes, you want to say something to the girl. You're like, this guy is such an ass.
嗯，他说她在夸大其词，说没那么严重，如果这就是你所经历的，没理由说你做不了家务，或者说了一些非常冒犯的话。有时你真的很想对那个女孩说点什么。你会觉得，这家伙真是个混蛋。
So can this humble machine change a man's mind? Eughan and Kasia are a great test case for this question because they do not see eye to eye about her periods at all. Eughan's from South Africa. Kasia is from Poland. They're both in their early 40s, and they're the kind of couple that is always talking past one another, constantly disagreeing.
那么这台谦卑的机器能改变一个男人的想法吗？尤根和卡西亚是检验这个问题的绝佳案例，因为他们在她的经期问题上完全无法达成共识。尤根来自南非。卡西亚来自波兰。他们都四十出头，属于那种总是话不投机、不断争论的情侣。
We've been married for 14 years. We have two big kids.
我们结婚14年了。我们有两个大孩子。
Well, not big. They're 10 and 7, but yes.
好吧，不算大。他们才10岁和7岁，但是的。
Even so, there was a real affection between them in a sort of old timey, the old ball and chain, is my spouse a real pain in the ass, kind of way.
即便如此，他们之间确实有一种怀旧的深情，那种“老伴，老妻，我的配偶真是个麻烦”的感觉。
She wants me to stop complaining.
她想让我别抱怨了。
Yeah, I think he thinks it's a choice we have as women when we get really cranky, and I'm like, it ain't a choice. It's what it is, and that's what it feels like.
是啊，我觉得他认为当我们变得情绪暴躁时这是我们可以选择的，而我说，这不是选择。这就是它的本来面目，这就是它的感觉。
As long as it's the real feeling.
只要那是真实的感受。
But I had a history of very, very difficult cramps. He thinks I'm difficult when I'm on my period. And I'm like, come on. I mean, I've got to be, right?
但我有过非常、非常困难的抽搐史。他觉得我月经期很难伺候。我说，拜托。我是说，我肯定会很难受，对吧？
Let's see.
我们来看看。
Eughan was actually the one who spotted the booth first and suggested they try it, which surprised Kasia. She said he's never displayed an interest in her period pain, though secretly, she wondered if he was doing it to see if she was exaggerating or at least prove his own toughness.
尤根实际上是第一个发现这个摊位并建议尝试的人，这让卡西亚很惊讶。她说他从未对她的经痛表现出兴趣，尽管她私下怀疑他这样做是为了看看她是否在夸大其词，或者至少证明自己的强硬。
Eughan and Kasia get hooked up to the simulator together so they'll feel the exact same thing at the exact same time. This way, Kasia can say to Eughan, this right here, this is what my cramps feel like. While they're hooking themselves up, Eughan repeatedly tells Kasia, don't cheat. And he looks over at her to make sure she's putting the pads on in the right place.
尤根和卡西亚一起连接到模拟器上，这样他们就能在同一时间感受到完全相同的东西。这样，卡西亚就可以对尤根说，就是现在，这就是我抽搐的感觉。在连接时，尤根反复告诉卡西亚，别作弊。他盯着她看，确保她把贴片贴在正确的位置。
Where's yours?
你的呢？
You're so skeptical of her.
你对她太怀疑了。
She'll cheat.
她会作弊的。
He thinks I'll cheat. Do you see what I'm dealing with?
他觉得我会作弊。你看到我在应付什么了吗？
So there are 10 levels. The first four levels are just kind of like a tingling sensation. 5 is when it drops to a lower frequency and should feel more like a cramp. 7 is what most people experience. And anything over 7 would be considered painful.
所以有10个等级。前四级只是一种刺痛感。5级时频率降低，感觉更像抽搐。7级是大多数人的体验。超过7级都被认为是痛苦的。
You're doing it evenly.
你调得很均匀。
I am. You really are skeptical.
是的。你真是太怀疑了。
Right? This is all about competition.
对吧？这完全是关于竞争的。
Eughan, for some reason, seems convinced that Lux might secretly crank his machine up while leaving Kasia on a lower level. Lux walks them through the levels. They get up to a level 6.
尤根不知为何坚信卢克斯可能在偷偷调高他的机器，而让卡西亚保持在较低水平。卢克斯引导他们经历各个级别。他们达到了6级。
That can't be how it feels.
不可能是这种感觉。
It feels really tight.
感觉真的很紧。
Wait, you said it can't be how it feels?
等等，你说不可能是这种感觉？
Never. The whole time?
从没这样过。全程都是？
Yeah.
对。
Up to seven days.
长达七天。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
对。
The next cramp comes.
下一次抽搐来了。
[SCREAMS] [LAUGHS] Done. Stop.
[尖叫][笑声] 好了。停。
No, we're going to 10.
不，我们要到10级。
You're going to stop? OK, it's off.
你要停下？好吧，关了。
Lux stops Eughan's machine, but keeps Kasia's on, who's now up to a level 9. Eughan does not want to join her.
卢克斯关掉了尤根的机器，但保持着卡西亚的机器运行，她现在达到了9级。尤根不想加入她。
Never do a 9. What was that? 8?
千万别做9级。那是什么？8级？
No, you got to do 9, Eughan. Come on.
不，你必须做9级，尤根。来吧。
No, no. No 9. Listen, I think this one's too high. It's like going through my stomach. I don't think that's how it can feel. Is that really how it feels? Is that how it feels, though?
不，不。没有9级。听着，我觉得这个太高了。它像是穿过了我的胃。我觉得不可能是这种感觉。真的会是这种感觉吗？尽管如此，是这种感觉吗？
This is period pain right now. I'm feeling it really cranking up.
这就是现在的经痛。我感觉到它真的在不断增强。
Don't do mine.
别弄我的。
Yeah. Oh, yeah, this is a period pain. Like, it's really deep into you. That's it.
对。哦，是的，这就是经痛。就像，它真的深入你的身体。就是这样。
Kasia eventually convinces Eughan to get back on the machine.
卡西亚最终说服尤根回到机器上。
Number 9. You got to do 9.
9级。你必须做9级。
But quick, if I say off, you off it, huh?
但很快，如果我说关，你就关掉，嗯？
No. [LAUGHS]
不。[笑声]
[SCREAMS]
[尖叫]
Yes.
是的。
[PANTS] It's like giving birth.
[喘息]这就像分娩一样。
Is this like giving birth?
这像分娩吗？
No.
不像。
You're doing 10 now? [SCREAMS] Is that 10? Is that 10? Is that 10? Is that on 10 now?
你现在做10级了？[尖叫]那是10级吗？那是10级吗？那是10级吗？现在是10级吗？
Yes.
是的。
Yes. That's a deep pain. Hold on. One more, and then we're done.
是的。那是一种深刻的疼痛。坚持住。再来一次，然后我们就结束。
You're squeezing her arm off.
你要把她的胳膊掐断了。
Yeah, no, he's hurting me. Yes. You know when the pain goes all the way to your back? That deep muscle pain that goes into your back? That's the period pain.
对，不，他在弄痛我。是的。你知道当疼痛一直传到你的背部吗？那种深入背部的肌肉深处的疼痛？那就是经痛。
The whole time?
一直都是这样？
The whole time continuously, yeah.
一直持续着，是的。
That's not nice, though.
那可不好。
It comes in waves.
它是一波一波来的。
But is that how it feels the whole time?
但全程都是那种感觉吗？
That really deep pain. And it literally feels like--
那种非常深刻的疼痛。它确实感觉像——
Why don't you make a scene about that?
你为什么不为此大吵大闹呢？
Do you think this will change the way that you interact with your partner?
你觉得这会改变你与伴侣互动的方式吗？
Definitely.
肯定的。
Really? In what way?
真的吗？以什么方式？
Well, now I will ask her are you having the same vibrations as you were? It's so tough.
嗯，现在我会问她，你感觉到的振动和我的一样吗？这太艰难了。
So do you feel like you believe her more now?
所以你觉得你现在更相信她了吗？
Definitely.
肯定的。
How come you think that you had to experience the pain yourself to believe her?
为什么你觉得你得亲身体验这种痛苦才会相信她？
To be honest, I just thought it's like mood changes.
老实说，我只是以为那只是情绪波动。
You thought she was just being whiny?
你以为她只是在发牢骚？
Whiny.
发牢骚。
Eughan went from, "My wife complains too much about period pain," to asking why she didn't make more of a scene during her period over the course of five minutes. So, theoretically, mission success.
尤根从“我妻子对经痛抱怨太多”，变成了询问她为什么在经期不表现得更痛苦一些。所以，理论上，任务成功。
A few days later, the longevity of Eughan's transformation was tested. He and Kasia were back at home in England, and Kasia had her period. She was sitting on the couch and told Eughan, I'm at a level 8 right now. He said, OK. He understood. Kasia told me, if you think he then got me a glass of water or a pillow or took care of me in some way, that's not the husband I have. But he acknowledged my pain, and that was new. And I appreciated it.
几天后，尤根改变的持久性得到了验证。他和卡西亚回到了英国的家中，卡西亚处于经期。她坐在沙发上告诉尤根，我现在8级。他说，好吧。他理解了。卡西亚告诉我，如果你以为他随后给我端了一杯水或拿了个枕头，或者以某种方式照顾我，那他就不是我丈夫。但他承认了我的痛苦，那是新鲜事。我很感激。
I'd flown to Calgary to watch men get hooked up to the simulator to see what they'd learn about period pain. I hadn't planned on learning anything about periods myself. I already have one. I figure, I know about them. But I was shocked by how many women offhandedly mentioned going to the hospital for their period pain. At first, I wasn't sure if I was just way more ignorant about period pain than I'd realized, or if I was just in Canada, where regular people can actually afford to go to the hospital with some regularity. It was probably both.
我飞到卡尔加里观看男人们连接模拟器，看看他们能了解到什么关于经痛的信息。我自己并没有计划去了解经期。我自己就有一个。我想，我很了解它们。但我被那么多女性随口提到因经痛而去医院的情况所震惊。起初，我不确定是我对经痛的无知远超预期，还是我只是因为在加拿大，普通人确实可以经常去医院。可能两者皆有。
But there were just so many women in so much pain, so much of the time, like this woman, Gabby, with endometriosis. She's 27. She has to walk with a cane. And she's applied for disability since the pain is so debilitating. And when I met her, she was about to fly to the US to pay for her second surgery, which costs about $40,000 out of pocket. Lux walked Gabby all the way up the scale on the simulator. She got to a 9, didn't blink.
但有太多女性长时间承受着剧痛，比如这位患有子宫内膜异位症的加比。她27岁。她不得不拄拐行走。她申请了残疾，因为疼痛令人极度虚弱。我遇见她时，她正准备飞往美国支付她的第二次手术费用，自费大约4万美元。卢克斯让加比在模拟器上调到了最高。她到了9级，连眼都没眨一下。
OK, do you want to try a 10?
好的，你想试一下10级吗？
Yeah.
是的。
OK, so this is a 10.
好的，这就是10级。
Yeah, it's like, it feels-- then you can feel a little bit more of the almost stabbies. I'm trying to figure out what this is on my pain scale. I mean, since I'm still standing, I would say this is probably like a-- this is probably like my everyday, like a 6. Yeah, no, I could definitely function with this.
是的，这感觉——然后你能感觉到更多几乎是刺痛的感觉。我正试图弄清楚在我的疼痛量表上这是什么。我是说，既然我还能站着，我想这大概是我平时的感觉，6级。是的，不，我绝对能忍受这个。
When I tried the machine, my level was 7, average. At levels 8, 9, and 10, I couldn't even speak. I was just silently breathing through the pain. It was so much worse than my cramps. And watching Gabby casually hold a conversation at level 10, I felt like I finally emotionally understood the whole point of the machine.
当我尝试这台机器时，我的等级是7级，平均水平。在8、9和10级时，我甚至无法说话。我只是默默地通过呼吸来忍受疼痛。这比我的抽搐严重得多。看着加比在10级时从容地进行对话，我终于在情感上理解了这台机器的全部意义。
It's easy to think that because you've experienced a piece of a thing, that you understand the entirety of it. But on the spectrum of period pain, Gabby's experience is as far from mine as mine is from the men. I felt angry that I somehow didn't know any of this before. And when I got home from Calgary, I couldn't stop talking about what I'd seen, asking everyone with the fervor of a college freshman who just learned about feminism, do you have any idea how much pain women are asked to endure?
很容易认为，因为你体验过事物的某一部分，你就理解了它的全部。但在经痛的谱系上，加比的体验离我非常遥远，就像我的体验离男人们的一样遥远。我感到愤怒，因为我竟然在之前一点都不知道这些。当我从卡尔加里回家时，我无法停止谈论我所看到的一切，带着刚学到女权主义的大一新生的热情问每个人，你们知不知道女性被要求承受多少痛苦？
Before this, I think a part of me felt like these guys were being kind of insensitive dummies, totally unaware of the pain of the people around them. But I guess I was basically as clueless as they were.
在此之前，我觉得一部分的我认为这些家伙是有些迟钝的傻瓜，完全没意识到周围人的痛苦。但我猜我基本上和他们一样无知。
Aviva DeKornfeld is a producer on our show.
阿维娃·德科恩费尔德是我们节目的制片人。
Act Two, "Face Your Demons." This next story is about a man who wants, more than anything in the world, to be able to see people around him accurately, which is not an easy thing to do. Our producer, Alix Spiegel, has the story.
第二幕，“直面你的恶魔”。这下一个故事关于一个男人，他比世界上任何东西都更希望能准确地看待周围的人，这可不是一件容易的事。我们的制片人阿利克斯·斯皮格尔带来了这个故事。
Love was always important to Jason Werbeloff-- probably the most important thing. As a kid growing up in South Africa, he often imagined his future partner, what the man might look, how close the two of them would be. Jason was crossing his fingers for the standard version of the love story, the one in all the movies.
爱对杰森·韦伯洛夫来说一直很重要——可能是最重要的事情。作为一个在南非长大的孩子，他经常想象未来的伴侣，那个人可能长什么样，两人会亲密到什么程度。杰森一直祈祷能有一个标准的爱情故事，电影里那种。
I was looking for a soulmate, the one, the person who would understand me, and complete my life, and allow me to fully connect with them on every level, and share every detail of ourselves-- I guess a very Disney way of thinking about life.
我在寻找一个灵魂伴侣，那个唯一的人，那个能理解我、完整我的人生，让我与他在各个层面充分连接，并分享我们每一个细节的人——我想这是一种非常迪士尼式的生命观。
So it felt like good news when, at the age of 24, Jason met Marius, an artist with thick black glasses who proudly held Jason's hand in public. This was 2008, and Jason had recently graduated from university with a degree in philosophy. He was out on his own, trying to get a life and a small software business up and running. And Marius was incredibly supportive, confident that Jason would succeed at whatever it is that he tried.
所以，当杰森24岁时遇到马里乌斯，感觉就像是个好消息，马里乌斯是一位戴着厚黑框眼镜的艺术家，在公共场合自豪地牵着杰森的手。那是2008年，杰森刚从大学毕业，获得了哲学学位。他当时独自在外面打拼，试图开创一份事业和一家小型软件公司。马里乌斯非常支持他，坚信杰森无论尝试什么都能成功。
He looked at me like I mattered. And I remember him laughing a lot. And he had a good laugh, very warm.
他看着我就像我对他很重要一样。我记得他经常笑。他笑声很好听，非常温暖。
But then one night, pretty early in the relationship, Jason had an experience that left him deeply shaken.
但随后，在恋爱初期的一个晚上，杰森经历了一次让他深受震动的体验。
So I remember we were sitting at a table at a restaurant. It was outside the movies. We were going to go see a movie that night. And I remember looking at him, and I thought he was snarling at me.
我记得我们当时坐在餐厅的桌边。那是电影院外面。我们那天晚上打算去看电影。我记得看着他，我想他在对我咆哮。
The expression on his boyfriend's face-- for a moment, Jason thought he saw a look of pure hatred. It was just a flash, but it was unnerving. It felt like Jason had seen a glimpse of something deeper, like the expression revealed some buried inner truth. Jason didn't think he'd said anything to offend his boyfriend. And there was nothing in his boyfriend's voice that was nasty or malicious. But the expression-- Marius looked like someone who clearly meant him ill.
他男朋友脸上的表情——有那么一瞬间，杰森以为他看到了纯粹的仇恨。那只是一瞬间，但却让人不安。感觉就像杰森看到了某种更深层的东西，好像那个表情揭示了某种埋藏的内心真相。杰森不觉得自己说了什么冒犯他男朋友的话。而且他男朋友的语气里也没有任何恶毒或恶意。但那个表情——马里乌斯看起来就像一个明显对他不怀好意的人。
I remember looking at his face and thinking, I don't want to be anywhere near this person. He feels like a stranger and like he wants to harm me, to hurt me.
我记得看着他的脸心想，我不想离这个人太近。他感觉像个陌生人，而且好像想伤害我，折磨我。
Did you say anything to him, like, why are you looking at me like that?
你对他说过什么吗，比如，你为什么那样看着我？
No, because I thought I must be misunderstanding. And I must just ask him enough questions to find out what he's feeling in order to understand him differently. And I started to ask him questions about how he felt about us, about what he wanted from the relationship. And he reacted in a very confused way. And that was our first fight.
没有，因为我以为一定是我理解错了。我必须多问他几个问题，找出他真实的感受，以便换个角度理解他。我开始问他关于我们之间的感觉，以及他从这段关系中想要什么的问题。他的反应非常困惑。那是我们的第一次争吵。
Jason eventually let it go, and the rest of the night was normal. Unfortunately, in the days and weeks that followed, those brief, menacing expressions, they continued. Jason kept catching Marius with a malicious look on his face, a kind of ghoulish snarl. Every time he saw it, he felt his heart race. The look was almost demonic.
杰森最终没再计较，那一晚剩下的时间也很正常。不幸的是，在接下来的日子和几周里，那些短暂的恶意表情依然存在。杰森不断捕捉到马里乌斯脸上露出恶意的神色，一种如同食尸鬼般的咆哮。每次看到，他都感到心跳加速。那个神情几乎是恶魔般的。
It wasn't all the time. And usually, the look would emerge and then disappear just as quickly, so Jason was never absolutely certain that what he thought he saw was what he saw. But still, it upset him almost every time. No matter how many times Marius told him that he was just imagining it, that Marius loved Jason and only wanted the best for him, Jason found the expressions impossible to ignore.
并不总是这样。通常表情出现后会迅速消失，所以杰森从未完全确定他以为自己看到的确实是真实的。但尽管如此，它几乎每次都让他感到不安。无论马里乌斯多少次告诉他，他只是在想象，马里乌斯爱着杰森并且只希望他好，杰森都觉得那些表情无法忽视。
We used to fight a lot. And it always felt like we had two relationships. There was the relationship I had with him when he looked like someone I could trust and love and the relationship I had with him when he looked awful. And the relationship felt very chaotic. It was good, and it was bad. And it was good, and it was bad. It was good, and it was bad.
我们以前经常吵架。感觉好像我们有两段关系。一段是我和他之间，当他看起来是可以信任和爱的人时的关系；另一段是他看起来很可怕时的关系。这种感觉非常混乱。它好坏交织。时好时坏。时好时坏。
I started to research facial expressions obsessively. So I read every book I could in my university's library. There were a few.
我开始疯狂地研究面部表情。所以我读了大学图书馆里我能找到的每一本书。有几本。
About facial expressions?
关于面部表情的？
Yes.
是的。
That's so interesting. Why? And what were you looking for in those books?
那太有意思了。为什么？你在书中寻找什么？
I basically wanted to be able to see a facial expression and be able to recognize what emotion was underlying it, what the person was feeling. I became obsessed with that. Because what I thought he was feeling and what he said he was feeling didn't match. So I became obsessed with working it out. What is it that's on this guy's face?
我基本上想通过观察面部表情，就能识别出 underlying（潜在的）情感，那个人到底感觉如何。我对这一点变得痴迷。因为我以为他感到的和我所说的他感到的不匹配。所以我痴迷于搞清楚这一点。这个家伙脸上到底是什么？
Marius and Jason were together for four years until, eventually, the expression problem came to a head. Jason says he remembers the exact moment. He'd come into a room where Marius was working on an art project.
马里乌斯和杰森在一起四年，直到最后，表情问题爆发了。杰森说他记得确切的时刻。他走进一个马里乌斯正在创作艺术项目的房间。
I just hated the way he looked at me. It looked like he was looking at me with contempt. And then a few months later, we broke up. It was just that particular look. It stayed with me.
我就是讨厌他看我的样子。看起来他看着我的时候充满了轻蔑。几个月后，我们就分手了。就是那个特定的眼神。它一直伴随着我。
And it wasn't only with Marius. This happened with other people, too, these flashes of apparent malice. It happened with his mother, some, though not all, of his friends, random strangers he encountered in the world. It wasn't everyone. It wasn't all the time. But it kept happening.
而且这不仅发生在马里乌斯身上。杰森和其他人在一起时也会发生这种情况，这些明显的恶意闪现。这发生在他母亲身上，一些朋友（尽管不是全部）身上，他在世界上遇到的陌生人身上。并不是每个人都这样。并不是一直这样。但这种情况一直在发生。
So Jason started to change his patterns. He went out with friends and family much less, even created a work-life where he could spend most of his time alone. He just couldn't stand to see the terrible expressions. And they bothered him most in the context of his romantic relationships, that part of his life where he had so hoped to find unconditional love and support.
所以杰森开始改变他的生活方式。他减少了与朋友和家人的外出，甚至创造了一种可以让他大部分时间独处的工作生活。他就是无法忍受看到那些可怕的表情。在恋爱关系中，这些表情让他感到最困扰，那本该是他最希望找到无条件的爱和支持的生活部分。
Jason desperately wanted a healthy relationship, and so he did the typical thing that people do when they're having trouble in love-- he consulted experts, went to see therapists, one after another.
杰森迫切地想要一段健康的关系，所以他做了人们在恋爱中遇到困难时通常会做的事——他咨询专家，去看心理医生，一个接一个。
I put myself into therapy.
我让自己接受了心理治疗。
And what did you say to the therapist, and what did they say to you about what the issue could be?
你对心理医生说了什么，他们对这个问题的原因有什么看法？
I said, the person I'm dating or this friend isn't someone that I can trust, isn't someone that I can feel close to. And then the second thing I would say is, what is wrong with me for feeling like that? Is it them, or is it me? But something's very wrong here. And I don't know what it is. But is it them, or is it me?
我说，我约会的人或者这个朋友不是我可以信任的人，不是我可以感到亲近的人。然后第二件事我会说，我为什么会这样想，我怎么了？是他们的问题，还是我的问题？但这里肯定有什么非常不对劲。我不知道是什么。到底是他们还是我？
And what did the therapist tend to say? Was it them, or was it you?
心理医生通常怎么说？是他们的问题，还是你的问题？
They would find some story to tell about that. Like, there either was something very wrong with them, or there was something very wrong with me wanting someone who I had such discomfort around.
他们会编出某种故事来解释。要么是对方有很大的问题，要么是我自己有问题，总是想要那种让我感到如此不舒服的人。
This went on for 13 years, and Jason withdrew more and more. Every romantic relationship ended the same way, with a look so terrifying, Jason could no longer stand it. In fact, in one case, the look on his boyfriend's face was so disturbing, Jason made him leave that instant, literally went online, paid for an Airbnb and told him to pack.
这种情况持续了13年，杰森变得越来越封闭。每一段恋爱关系的结局都一样，那种眼神是如此恐怖，杰森再也无法忍受。事实上，有一次，他男朋友脸上的眼神是如此令人不安，杰森让他立刻离开，直接上网订了爱彼迎并叫他打包。
But then, about three years ago, Jason stumbled on the source of this problem. And understanding what it was made him think about his whole life differently. It started one day when he was on this online forum and got into a conversation with a woman named Catherine. Jason described to Catherine his experience with faces, the strange flashes he saw that haunted him for days afterwards.
但大约三年前，杰森偶然发现了这个问题的根源。明白这是什么之后，让他重新审视了整个人生。有一天，他在一个在线论坛上与一位名叫凯瑟琳的女性进行交谈。杰森向凯瑟琳描述了他对人脸的体验，那些困扰他好几天的奇怪闪现。
And Catherine told him that she thought she knew what his problem was. She said the name of a disorder that he'd never heard of, then told him that to figure out if he had it, he should purchase this special light, which allows the user to change the color of the light through the full color spectrum.
凯瑟琳告诉他，她认为自己知道他的问题是什么。她说出了一种他闻所未闻的疾病名称，然后告诉他，要确定是否有这种病，他应该买这种特殊的灯，它允许用户通过整个色谱改变光线的颜色。
I thought she was a bit of a quack, to be honest. [CHUCKLES] I thought, she doesn't know what she's talking about. But I'll humor her and get these colored bulbs for my lights. And she said, sit in a perfectly dark room with no other light sources, and put a lamp on either side of you so there's no shadows. And look in the mirror and change the colors on the spectrum and see what you see.
老实说，我当时认为她有点是个庸医。[轻笑] 我心想，她根本不知道自己在说什么。但我还是会迁就她，买这些彩色灯泡。她说，坐在一个完全黑暗的房间里，不要其他光源，在你的两侧各放一盏灯，这样就不会有阴影。看着镜子，变换光谱上的颜色，看看你会看到什么。
Now, when Jason was a kid and, really, all through high school, he told me he'd felt pretty good about the way that he looked. He considered himself reasonably attractive. But when he was in his mid-twenties, that started to change.
现在，杰森小时候，甚至整个高中时期，他告诉我他对自己长相的感觉还不错。他认为自己很有吸引力。但当他二十多岁时，这一切开始改变。
What Jason saw when he looked in the mirror was someone whose right eye kind looked out of place and was much smaller than the other one, and he decided he wasn't very attractive. He was kind of a strange-looking guy. So anyway, Jason sits down in his bedroom and arranges the light, just like the woman said. And then he looks in the mirror.
当杰森照镜子时，他看到一个人的右眼看起来不对劲，比另一只眼睛小得多，他决定自己长得并不好看。他是个长相奇怪的家伙。所以，总之，杰森坐在卧室里，像那个女人说的那样安排好了灯光。然后他看着镜子。
And I sort of went around the color dial. And when the color was green, my eye was not smaller and to the side and higher than the other eye. It was where it should be on a symmetrical face.
我拨弄了一下颜色转盘。当颜色是绿色时，我的眼睛没有比另一只眼睛更小、偏向一边和更高。它处于对称人脸应有的位置。
How did that make you feel?
这让你感觉如何？
I was amazed. I was like-- I was truly amazed by how I looked. And suddenly, things started to pop into place, all of a sudden, in my head. It was because I've always had-- I don't want to sound arrogant, but I've always had a lot of attention from other men.
我很惊讶。我当时——我真的对自己看起来的样子感到非常惊讶。突然之间，一切都开始就位了，在我脑海中。这是因为我一直有——我不想显得傲慢，但我一直受到很多男性的关注。
And I could never understand why because I thought, I don't know what these people are seeing in me. But I'm not a pretty person. I have a really ugly face. Why are they doing this? Which would feed into a paranoia about, are they trying to use me in some way? They can't possibly be attracted to me.
我永远无法理解为什么，因为我想，我不知道这些人看到了什么。但我不是个漂亮的人。我有一张非常丑陋的脸。他们为什么要这样做？这会导致偏执，他们是在试图利用我吗？他们不可能被我吸引。
But suddenly, under the green lights, my face was not distorted. I didn't see the face as it was before as a distortion. I thought that was reality. And I was really shocked. I felt thrown, and I couldn't stop staring.
但突然，在绿光下，我的脸没有变形。我不认为以前看到的脸是变形的。我以为那是现实。我真的很震惊。我感到被震撼了，无法停止凝视。
But then Jason turned the dial.
但接着杰森转动了转盘。
And the opposite color to green on the color wheel is red. And I took the dial all the way to red, and I stared at my face in the mirror. And my face became truly demonic. Like, I remember it was so intense, it felt like everything around my face went completely black. And the change that I'd seen in so many people over years and years and years was concentrated and magnified and crystallized on my face.
色轮上与绿色相对的颜色是红色。我把转盘一直转到红色，盯着镜子里的自己。我的脸变得极其邪恶。就像，我记得它太强烈了，感觉好像我脸周围的一切都彻底变黑了。我在多年里看到的很多人的变化，都在我的脸上被集中、放大并结晶了。
And I looked so terrible. And the difference between myself and the green light and the red light was so massive. It was like a terrifying experience. And I switched the light off. I couldn't look at myself for long. And I cried. I sobbed.
我看起来太可怕了。我和绿光下及红光下的自己之间的差异是如此巨大。那是一种极其恐怖的体验。我关掉了灯。我不能看自己太久。我哭了。我抽泣着。
It turned out that Jason had an actual neurological condition. There was a name for what was going on.
事实证明，杰森患有一种真实的神经系统疾病。这种病有名字。
It's this condition called PMO, prosopometamorphopsia.
这是一种叫PMO的病，面部变形症。
Say it again?
再说一遍？
Prosopometamorphopsia.
面部变形症（Prosopometamorphopsia）。
That's a lot of-- a lot of vowels.
那有很多——很多元音。
[LAUGHS] And it's actually worse than that because the particular kind I have is called hemi-prosopometamorphopsia.
[笑声]而且实际上比这更糟，因为我患的那种特定的叫半面部变形症。
Not much is known about PMO. It's extremely rare. But for people with the disorder, facial features distort, melting and swelling until the expression of the person is so twisted, it looks demonic, an exaggerated snarl that, for Jason, was impossible to tell wasn't real. And sitting in that dark room, looking at his face in the mirror, suddenly the last 13 years made a certain morbid sense to Jason.
关于PMO知之甚少。它极其罕见。但对于患有这种障碍的人来说，面部特征会扭曲，融化并肿胀，直到那个人的表情变得如此扭曲，看起来就像恶魔，一种夸张的咆哮，对于杰森来说，无法区分这是否真实。坐在那个黑暗的房间里，看着镜子里的脸，突然间，过去13年里的事情对杰森来说产生了一种病态的意义。
So that was the very first time that you realized that none of this was real, that it was all just a projection?
所以那是你第一次意识到这一切都不是真实的，这都只是幻觉？
Yeah. It gives me goosebumps now to think about it. It felt like the biggest thing of my whole life, bigger than anything.
是的。现在想起来都起鸡皮疙瘩。这感觉像是我一生中最大的事，比什么都大。
Since he found out, Jason's been working with a researcher at Dartmouth who studies this condition, a man named Brad Duchaine. And looking back, they realized that all of his symptoms started after he'd had this really bad case of mono in his early 20s, right before he started dating Marius, actually. So they think that that's what caused it. PMO seems like it can come on after an illness or trauma to the brain.
自从发现以后，杰森一直与达特茅斯大学的一位研究这种状况的科学家合作，那个人叫布拉德·杜尚。回顾过去，他们意识到他所有的症状都是在他20岁出头时得了那次严重的单核细胞增多症之后开始的，实际上就在他开始和马里乌斯约会之前。所以他们认为这就是导致的原因。PMO似乎可能在患病或大脑创伤后出现。
And here's another quirk of the disorder. For some people, including Jason, the distortions are harder to notice if the person he's looking at is wearing glasses, because, apparently, glasses interrupt the typical way that a face is processed by the brain. It's an obstruction that kind of resets things. So if you wear glasses, you can look perfectly fine.
这是该疾病的另一个奇特之处。对于一些人，包括杰森，如果他看着的那个人戴着眼镜，这种扭曲就很难被察觉，因为显然，眼镜干扰了大脑处理人脸的典型方式。这是一种阻塞，有点像重置了系统。所以如果你戴眼镜，你看上去就完全正常。
But even knowing all this, it's obvious that it's still surprisingly hard for Jason to put aside something that he's seeing with his own eyes. Jason has literally spent months working with researchers, building a detailed understanding of his disorder and how it changes his visual experience. But still, emotionally, it's just so hard to ignore.
但即使知道这一切，显然，杰森仍然很难把亲眼所见的东西抛诸脑后。杰森确实花了几个月的时间与研究人员一起工作，对他的障碍以及它是如何改变他的视觉体验建立了详细的理解。但即便如此，在情感上，它就是很难被忽视。
Like one time, Jason and I were talking over Zoom, which is typically a little bit tough for Jason, because if he has to look directly at a face for too long, it'll distort. But fortunately, I was wearing glasses.
就像有一次，我和杰森在Zoom上交谈，这对他来说通常有点困难，因为如果他必须盯着一张脸太久，它就会扭曲。但幸运的是，我戴着眼镜。
So your face is totally fine now. There's zero changes.
所以你现在脸看起来完全没问题。没有任何变化。
Because I have glasses on?
因为我戴着眼镜？
Yeah. If you took them off--
对。如果你摘掉它——
So if I took off my glasses, then what happens?
所以如果我摘掉眼镜，会发生什么？
So now your right eye is moving up, and it's starting to move across. OK, so now this part of your nose is getting dark and pushing in.
那么现在你的右眼在向上移动，开始向一侧移动。好的，现在你鼻子的这一部分变黑并向里推。
The bridge of my nose.
我鼻梁。
This top of your nose-- yeah, it flattens into your face. And then this part of your cheek drifts out, bulges out.
你鼻子顶部——是的，它变平了。然后你脸颊的这一部分漂移出来，鼓出来了。
Mm-hmm. And do I look angry at you?
嗯哼。那我看起来对你生气吗？
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。
And does it affect the way that you feel about me right now?
那它会影响你现在对我的感觉吗？
Yeah. I try not to let it because I know. My conscious mind knows that that's not real, but my unconscious feels the threat. And when I look at a face front on intensely for a while, my heart rate goes up. My voice catches in my throat. It just feels uncomfortable. It's not a nice experience. And I just instinctively keep looking away and back so that I don't have to see it.
会。我尽量不让它发生，因为我知道。我的意识知道那不是真的，但我的潜意识感到了威胁。当我盯着一张人脸看久了，我的心率就会上升。我的喉咙会哽咽。感觉很不舒服。这不是一种美好的体验。我只是本能地不断看向别处再回头，这样我就不必看到它。
Here, let me put on my glasses. Now, I'm perfectly fine, right?
来，让我戴上眼镜。现在，我看起来完全正常，对吧？
Perfectly fine. Yeah, yeah. In fact, for me, you're now a different person. So, I feel quite warm towards this person, but the other person, I didn't really like.
完全正常。对，对。事实上，对我来说，你现在是另一个人。所以，我对这个人感到很温暖，但另一个人，我真的不喜欢。
For all those years, all those relationships, Jason had been seeing the world through a distorted lens and didn't know it. Now that he knows, Jason has developed workarounds that he didn't have before. Like when he goes out to dinner, he sits next to a person, not across from them. He also has green lights for his home. All of that has eased things. He even has a partner now. They've been together for a while.
在那些年里，所有的那些关系里，杰森一直在透过扭曲的镜片看世界而自己却不知道。既然他知道了，杰森开发了一些他以前没有的变通方法。就像他出去吃饭时，他坐在那个人的旁边，而不是对面。他在家里也用绿色的光。所有这些都缓解了情况。他甚至现在有了一个伴侣。他们在一起有一段时间了。
Do you think he's somebody that you could have the kind of relationship with that you imagined as a child?
你认为他是一个你可以像儿时想象的那样与之建立关系的人吗？
No.
不。
Because it's hard to live with somebody or?
因为和某人住在一起很难，还是？
Yeah. We did live together for a while, for about six months, and it was very hard. It's not just that faces change. It's that I've built up a whole lifestyle around that where I go to sleep very late so that I'm not around people, so that I can spend a lot of time by myself. I've built up a whole way of coping with this. And living with someone really undermines a lot of that. And it was very hard for me.
是的。我们确实一起住过一段时间，大约六个月，非常艰难。不仅仅是脸会变的问题。而是我已经围绕那个现象建立了一种生活方式，我睡得很晚，这样我就不需要和人打交道，这样我就可以花很多时间一个人呆着。我已经建立了一整套应对的方法。而和人住在一起确实破坏了其中的很多东西。对我来说那非常困难。
Do you think that you'll ever be able to really, really, really trust a romantic partner?
你认为你以后还能真正、真正地去信任一个恋爱伴侣吗？
Not as long as I have eyes. Yeah.
只要我还有眼睛，就不可能。
For the rest of his life, Jason will be surrounded by the faces of demons, and he says his heart will always jump when he sees them because it always, always does. But he knows he doesn't have to listen to those warnings, that the ghouls that he sees are only projections. They mean him no harm.
在余下的生命里，杰森将一直被恶魔的面孔所包围，他说当他看到它们时他的心总是会跳动，因为事实总是、总是如此。但他知道他不必听信那些警告，他所看到的恶鬼只是投影。它们对他并没有恶意。
Alix Spiegel is a producer on our show. Coming up, a person finds a way to create an almost unlimited quantity of gold. What could go wrong? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
阿利克斯·斯皮格尔是我们节目的制片人。接下来的故事，一个人找到了一种创造几乎无限数量黄金的方法。可能会出什么差错？在芝加哥公共广播电台的一分钟后，我们的节目将继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Tobin Low, in for Ira Glass. Today's show, How Are You Not Seeing This? Stories of people struggling to agree about what's right in front of their faces. We're at Act Three. Act Three, "Pump It Up."
这里是《美国生活》。我是托宾·洛，代班艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是，《你们怎么还没发现？》。关于人们在面对面时，在如何达成共识的问题上挣扎的故事。我们来到第三幕。第三幕，“泵起来”。
So in this next story, the fate of the entire world is at stake. And one person finds himself completely alone, surrounded by people who just do not get what has to happen. The person is our very own David Kestenbaum.
所以在这个接下来的故事里，全世界的命运危在旦夕。一个人发现自己孤立无援，周围的人就是无法明白必须发生什么。这个人就是我们自己的大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。
And the thing that he was trying to do was to replace the furnace in his house with a heat pump. The furnace he was replacing ran off natural gas, a fossil fuel. The heat pump, much greener, runs off electricity and can miraculously both heat and cool. When David saw the federal government was offering people $2,000 tax credits to switch to heat pumps, he figured it would be easy. It was not. David here has this, uh, guide as how to get your heat pump and tax credit.
他试图做的事情是用热泵更换家里的炉子。他更换的炉子靠天然气运行，那是一种化石燃料。更环保的热泵靠电力运行，神奇地既能制热也能制冷。当大卫看到联邦政府向换用热泵的人提供2000美元税收抵免时，他认为这很简单。事实并非如此。大卫这里有一份关于如何获得热泵和税收抵免的指南。
If you want to get a heat pump, you'll start with the usual thing of asking a bunch of HVAC companies to come out and give you estimates. They'll pull up in their little vans with the company's names on the side, poke around your house, measure some things. You'll tell them you want a heat pump.
如果你想买一个热泵，你会从常规的事情开始，让几家暖通空调公司出来给你评估。他们会开着喷有公司名称的小货车过来，在你的房子里翻翻找找，测量一些东西。你会告诉他们你想要一个热泵。
They'll say they usually install gas furnaces, and why don't you stick with that? You'll tell them you're worried about climate change. And, you point out, the heat pump is actually a little cheaper when you include the new tax credit. You just need to make sure the one they install qualifies for the tax credit, which is when they'll tell you they've never heard of the tax credit, even though it's been around for a year.
他们会说他们通常安装燃气炉，为什么不继续用那个呢？你会告诉他们你担心气候变化。而且，你指出，加上新的税收抵免后，热泵实际上更便宜一点。你只需要确保他们安装的那个符合税收抵免条件，这时他们会告诉你，他们从来没听说过税收抵免，尽管这已经出台一年了。
Undeterred, after they leave, you'll go to the IRS website because you want to make sure you get a heat pump that qualifies. On the IRS website, you'll find this-- heat pumps with a thermal efficiency rating of at least 75% qualify. That seems simple, except you won't know what thermal efficiency rating is. No matter because it turns out this is wrong.
不屈不挠，他们走后，你会去国税局网站，因为你想确保你买的热泵符合条件。在国税局网站上，你会发现这个——热效率等级至少为75%的热泵符合条件。这看起来很简单，除了你不知道什么是热效率等级。没关系，因为事实证明这是错的。
You'll find out this is wrong from a second IRS document, which is very clear. It says, in order to get your $2,000, the heat pump must satisfy, quote, "the energy efficiency requirements in Q1." You may wonder if Q1 refers to the first financial quarter. It does not.
你会从第二份国税局文件中发现这是错的，这份文件非常清楚。它说，为了获得那2000美元，热泵必须满足，引用，“Q1中的能源效率要求”。你可能想知道Q1是否指的是第一财务季度。并不是。
It refers to question 1 further down in the document, which says that heat pumps must, quote, "meet or exceed the highest efficiency tier, not including any advanced tier, established by the Consortium for Energy Efficiency that is in effect as of the beginning of the year in which the property is placed in service." This will fill you with despair until you see that there is a searchable database of equipment that'll meet the qualifications. That sounds great, but there is no link.
它指的是文档下方的问题1，该问题称热泵必须，引用，“达到或超过能源效率联盟设立的最高效率等级，不包括任何高级等级，该等级在财产投入使用当年年初生效”。这会让你充满绝望，直到你看到有一个可以搜索的设备数据库符合条件。听起来不错，但没有链接。
So you google around and find a government website that has a link with instructions for how to use the database. But the link does not load. You will wait five minutes for it to load because you figure it'll sort itself out. But it does not. You try back the next day, and no, it really does not seem to exist.
所以你四处谷歌搜索，找到了一个政府网站，上面有关于如何使用数据库的说明链接。但链接无法加载。你会等上五分钟，以为它会自己恢复正常。但并没有。第二天你再试，不，它真的好像不存在。
The only way forward seems to be to look up the actual requirements for you to get your $2,000 tax credit. You go to the Consortium for Energy Efficiency website, where you will finally find it spelled out. And I am going to have to spell here because these are not words. The heat pumps SEER2, EER2, HSPF2, and COP measured at 5 degrees Fahrenheit, all have to be above certain values.
唯一的出路似乎是查询你获得2000美元税收抵免的实际要求。你去了能源效率联盟的网站，在那里你终于会看到它被拼写出来。我在这里得拼写一下，因为这些不是词。测量在5华氏度下的热泵SEER2、EER2、HSPF2和COP值都必须高于特定数值。
You will also learn here a fact skipped over elsewhere. If you are in the northern US, there are different requirements. You'll need a cold climate rated one. At this point, you will cry because how are we ever going to solve climate change if this is what it takes to get one heat pump installed in one house?
你还会在这里学到一个在其他地方被忽略的事实。如果你在美国北部，要求是不同的。你需要一个冷气候评级的产品。在这一点上，你会哭出来，因为如果安装一个热泵到一个房子里都需要这样，我们怎么可能解决气候变化问题？
At some point in your searches, you will find something hopeful-- a government web page that seems designed for simple people like you, energystar.gov. It's run by the EPA, and it's friendly, with iStock type photos of parents playing happily with children on couches. This is where you should have been all along.
在你的搜索过程中，你最终会找到一些充满希望的东西——一个似乎为像你这样的普通人设计的政府网页，energystar.gov。它由环保署运营，很友好，配有父母在沙发上与孩子愉快玩耍的图片。这本该是你一直以来应该去的地方。
It's basically a database with a nice, clean design. It shows you a giant list of heat pumps. There are search filters on the left-hand side. There's even a box for tax credit eligible. So you check that. And now it's showing only heat pumps it says are tax credit eligible.
它基本上是一个设计简洁、干净的数据库。它向你展示了一个巨大的热泵列表。左侧有搜索过滤器。甚至有一个复选框显示“符合税收抵免条件”。所以你勾选了它。现在它只显示它声称符合税收抵免条件的热泵。
But you soon realize there was a problem. It's not taking into account the fact that the requirements are different if you live in northern states. This seems really bad. It should say, if you live in the north, only these ones. There is a box to check for cold climate certified for people who live in the north. But if you click that, for some reason, it doesn't change the search results.
但你很快意识到有一个问题。它没有考虑如果你住在北部各州要求不同的事实。这看起来真的很糟。它应该显示，如果你住在北部，只有这些符合。这里有一个针对住在北部的人勾选“冷气候认证”的方框。但如果你点击那个，出于某种原因，搜索结果并不会改变。
You will puzzle over this for a long time and finally realize, even though you are asking it to show you things that are tax credit eligible and cold climate certified, it is showing you things that qualify for either, not both. Because you are a journalist, you will reach out to the EPA about this.
你会为此苦思冥想很久，最终意识到，尽管你要求它显示符合税收抵免条件且经过冷气候认证的产品，但它显示的是符合其中任何一个的产品，而不是同时符合两个。因为你是记者，你会就此联系环保署。
There will be a very awkward 20-minute interview with a public affairs specialist named Denise, who will seem surprised by this fact, that when you click on cold climate certified, it still shows you things that are not cold climate certified. Denise will click and see this for herself.
会有一个非常尴尬的20分钟采访，对象是一位名叫丹尼丝的公共事务专员，她似乎对这个事实感到惊讶，即当你点击“冷气候认证”时，它仍然显示那些没有经过冷气候认证的产品。丹尼丝会点击并亲眼看到这一点。
Then, another press person on the call will interrupt to ask, if the whole interview can instead be on background, if they can get you someone else to talk to. They will not get you someone else to talk to. They will not fix the website. Two months will pass. They will send an update saying they are waiting for a possible update from the IRS about which heat pumps qualify.
然后，电话里的另一位新闻工作人员会打断，询问采访是否可以改为背景说明，是否可以给你换个人谈。他们不会给你换个人谈。他们不会修复网站。两个月过去了。他们会发一份更新，说他们在等待国税局关于哪些热泵符合条件的可能更新。
You do eventually buy what you hope is a heat pump that qualifies. A nice man named Algernon will come over with a crew and install it in a few hours. This is really nice, he will say. I think I might get one for myself.
你确实最终买了一个你希望符合条件的热泵。一个叫阿尔杰农的好人会带着团队过来，在几个小时内安装好。他说，这真的很棒。我想我可能会给自己也买一个。
David Kestenbaum is our senior editor. Months after David talked to the EPA, just recently, the government did finally fix the website. The URL is www.energystar.gov/productfinder/product/certified-heat-pumps/results. Then you got to click a couple more times on the right things, and then at the end, select the Data tab. Anyway, good luck.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们的资深编辑。大卫和环保署交谈几个月后，就在最近，政府终于修复了网站。网址是www.energystar.gov/productfinder/product/certified-heat-pumps/results。然后你还得在右边的正确选项上多点几下，最后选择“数据”标签。总之，祝你好运。
Act Four, "I'm Great. Thanks for Not Asking." This last story's about a person going through something, and they want to share it with their friend. But that can be hard sometimes.
第四幕，“我很好。谢谢你没问。”这最后一个故事关于一个人正在经历某些事情，他们想和朋友分享。但有时这很难。
It's a short story by Marie Philips. Here's Marie.
这是一个由玛丽·菲利普斯创作的短篇故事。这是玛丽。
We meet at the bar that you chose, 20 minutes from your place and an hour from mine. I'm five minutes early. You're 25 minutes late. You text me that you're on your way and ask me to order you a gin and tonic. The ice is already half melted when you flop down in your seat and say, "My god, it's been forever. How are you?"
我们在你选的酒吧见面，离你家20分钟，离我家一小时。我早到了5分钟。你迟到了25分钟。你发短信给我说你在路上，并让我帮你点一杯金汤力。当你瘫坐在座位上说“天哪，简直是永远不见了。你怎么样？”时，冰已经化了一半了。
But I can see in your eyes that "how are you" is not a genuine question. It's just a piece of perfunctory politeness, a chance to give me a sentence or two before we get down to the real business of the evening, which is talking about you.
但我能从你的眼睛里看出来，“你怎么样”不是一个真诚的问题。这只是例行公事的礼貌，是让我说一两句话的机会，然后我们就会进入当晚的正题，也就是谈论你。
I don't know how this happened. We used to share everything. But lately, I feel like you've been slipping away from me and taking less and less interest in my life. So I know that you don't want me to tell you about what it's like to still be living with my mum in a sketchy suburb of South London that you've never visited because you can't reach it on the Underground.
我不知道这是怎么发生的。我们过去分享一切。但最近，我觉得你在从我身边溜走，对我生活的兴趣越来越少。所以我知道你不想听我说，在伦敦南部一个 sketchy（可疑/贫穷）郊区依然和我妈妈住在一起是什么感觉，那个你从来没去过的地方，因为地铁到不了那儿。
You don't want to know about how broke we got, how we resorted to selling our possessions on eBay or, rather, how I resorted to selling my mum's possessions with her permission because she still finds the internet confusing and asks me what her passwords are 50 times per day. I don't know, Mum. They're not my passwords. Why don't you write them down?
你不想知道我们穷到什么地步，我们如何诉诸于在eBay上卖掉我们的财产，或者更确切地说，我如何诉诸于在妈妈同意的情况下卖掉她的财产，因为她仍然觉得互联网很困惑，每天问我50次她的密码是什么。我不知道，妈妈。那不是我的密码。为什么你不写下来？
You don't want to hear about how I got catfished by some guy into selling him our beloved cow for some beans, the cow who lived in our garden, which, contrary to what our neighbors say, is completely legal. It's just that most people don't have one. Anyway, I sold her for beans.
你不想听我说，我是如何被某个家伙忽悠，用我们心爱的牛换了他的一些豆子，那头住在我们花园里的牛，这与我们的邻居所说的相反，完全是合法的。只是大多数人没有牛。总之，我用她换了豆子。
And what would happen if I told you how my mum yelled and yelled at me about these stupid beans and how I threw them in the compost heap, and then the next day, there was a beanstalk that went all the way up to the sky? You'd probably just hijack the conversation to say that you're growing tomatoes this year. If you cared, you'd know that my garden is north-facing and tomatoes won't grow there. And I love tomatoes. I really do.
如果我告诉你妈妈是如何为这些愚蠢的豆子对我大喊大叫，以及我是如何把它们扔进堆肥堆的，然后第二天，那里有一棵一直长到天上的豆茎，会发生什么呢？你很可能会劫持谈话，说你今年正在种番茄。如果你在乎，你会知道我的花园是朝北的，番茄不会在那里生长。而且我喜欢番茄。我真的喜欢。
I'm not going to tell you about how I climbed that beanstalk because I don't want to hear about your triathlon training, actually. As it happens, there was a land out there and a house with a giant living in it. But I'm going to keep that to myself. You'd only ask about what the property values are up in the sky in beanstalk land, and would it be a nice place to have a second home.
我不打算告诉你我是怎么爬上那棵豆茎的，因为我不想听关于你铁人三项训练的事情，真的。碰巧，那上面有一片陆地，还有一座住着巨人的房子。但我会把那件事藏在心里。你只会问天空中的豆茎之地的房地产价值是多少，那会是个买第二套房的好地方吗。
If you really cared how I am, you'd read my newsletter. And you'd already know that when I got to the house, the giant said, "Fee Fi Fo Fum, I smell the blood of an Englishman. Be he live or be he dead, I'll grind his bones to make my bread." You obviously didn't read my essay on what it was like to be misgendered by a cannibal.
如果你真的关心我怎么样，你会读我的通讯。你就会知道，当我到达那所房子时，巨人说，“Fee Fi Fo Fum，我闻到了英国人的血。不论他是活的还是死的，我都要磨碎他的骨头来做我的面包。”你显然没读过我关于被食人族误称性别是什么感觉的文章。
If we were still true friends, maybe I would trust you enough to tell you how I had to hide in the oven, an oven that other humans had literally been cooked in, until the giant fell asleep. And then I stole a bag of gold from him on the way out. I don't want a lecture. In my opinion, it's restorative justice. But whatever.
如果我们还是真正的朋友，也许我会信任你，告诉你我是如何不得不躲进烤箱里，一个人类真正被煮过烤箱，直到巨人睡着。然后我在离开的路上从他那儿偷了一袋金子。我不想被说教。在我看来，这是恢复性正义。但随便吧。
Anyway, it doesn't matter, because as you were so fond of reminding me, I'm terrible at budgeting, and I canned the lot on the Real Real. Yes, the gold is all gone. So I had to go back up the beanstalk.
总之，这不重要，因为正如你喜欢提醒我的那样，我擅长预算，我把钱全花在Real Real上了。是的，金子全没了。所以我不得不回到豆茎上。
I can just picture you stifling a yawn as I tell you how I went through the whole Fee Fi Fo thing again, and that this time, there wasn't a bag of gold, just a goose that lays golden eggs, and how I took her instead. Do you want to know how she is, too? Pretty discombobulated at living in South London. She doesn't like the traffic noise. Plus, as it turns out, it's quite hard to find someone who'll cash a golden egg for you and not ask too many questions about where you got it.
当你讲述我如何再次经历整个Fee Fi Fo的事情时，我可以想象你强压哈欠的样子，这一次，没有金袋子，只有一只会下金蛋的鹅，以及我是如何带走她的。你想知道她怎么样了吗？对于住在伦敦南部感到非常困惑。她不喜欢交通噪音。而且，事实证明，很难找到一个愿意为你兑现金蛋而不问你从哪儿得到的人。
No, I do not want to hear that you have a guy. I still remember what it was like when I called the accountant you recommended, and she told me that she doesn't do jobs that small. Geese don't lay eggs forever. And ours has already started to slow down, fewer and fewer all the time. I doubt you care that once a goose has lost her fertility, she's considered worthless. But for me? Hard identify.
不，我不想听你有路子。我还记得当我打电话给推荐的会计师时是什么感觉，她告诉我她不做那么小的活。鹅不会永远下蛋。我们的鹅已经开始慢下来了，越来越少。我怀疑你不在乎一旦鹅失去了生育能力，她就被视为一文不值。但对我来说？ Hard identify（很难定义/认同）。
I'm not going to tell you about that, though, because you have no idea how it feels to be approaching midlife while childless. Otherwise you would not keep going on at me about how you were transformed by parenthood. And only now do you know the true meaning of love. You will never know the beauty of becoming close to a bird.
不过，我不打算告诉你这件事，因为你根本不知道临近中年却膝下无子是什么感觉。否则你不会一直对我念叨你是如何被为人父母所改变。而且只有现在你才知道爱的真正含义。你永远不会知道与一只鸟变得亲密的美丽。
Though, having said that, because of the no more eggs thing, which could happen any day now, she will not solve our financial woes indefinitely. Plus, can you imagine what it's like to be financially dependent on a menopausal goose? No, I don't think you can. Oh, by the way, does your husband still run that hedge fund?
虽然话虽如此，因为没有更多蛋的事情，这随时可能发生，她不会无限期地解决我们的经济困境。此外，你能想象经济上依赖一只更年期的鹅是什么感觉吗？不，我觉得你不能。哦，对了，你丈夫还在经营那个对冲基金吗？
Well, anyway, I discussed it with my mum, and we decided that I had to go back up the beanstalk. She couldn't do it because she has problems with her knees. Not that you asked how she is. So, Fee Fi Fo Fum again. That little sting of being misgendered for the third time, but don't worry about it.
嗯，总之，我和妈妈讨论过了，我们决定我必须回到豆茎上去。她做不到，因为她膝盖有问题。不是你问她怎么样了。所以，再次 Fee Fi Fo Fum。第三次被误称性别的那种小刺痛，但别担心。
And the long and the short of it is that I stole a talking harp who kept yelling out, "Master, master!" because he has Stockholm syndrome or something. And the giant heard it and chased us down the beanstalk. And I was freaking out like, this is it! I am literally toast! But I got to the bottom first, and I chopped down the beanstalk with my mother's ax. And it came crashing to the ground, and the giant died.
简而言之，我偷走了一把会说话的竖琴，它一直在尖叫，“主人，主人！”因为它有斯德哥尔摩综合征什么的。巨人听到了，顺着豆茎追了下来。我当时快吓疯了，心想，就是现在！我真要完蛋了！但我先到了底部，用我妈妈的斧头砍断了豆茎。它重重地摔在地上，巨人死了。
But why would I tell you that? You'd just miss the point completely and ask some irrelevant question, like why does my mother have an ax? The thing is, though, I miss you. We used to have so much in common before you met your husband and started hanging out with his North London friends.
但我为什么要告诉你这些呢？你只会完全抓不住重点，问一些无关紧要的问题，比如我妈妈为什么会有斧头？不过重点是，我想你。在你遇到你丈夫并开始和他伦敦北部的那些朋友鬼混之前，我们过去有很多共同点。
I remember when we were teenagers, and you ran away from home. You were living in a houseshare and working as a cleaner after school. You knew what it was like to go through tough times.
我记得我们十几岁的时候，你离家出走。你住在合租房里，放学后做清洁工。你知道经历艰难时刻是什么感觉。
Back then, you would ask me how I am and mean it. I wish I could find the right words, the right question to remind you of that time, to bring you back to me. But instead. I take a sip from my warm white wine and say, "I'm fine. How are you? Do you ever hear from those seven dwarves?"
那时候，你会问我怎么样，并且是真心的。我真希望我能找到合适的词，合适的问题来提醒你那段时光，把你带回我身边。但相反，我啜了一口温白葡萄酒说，“我很好。你呢？你还会从那七个小矮人那里收到消息吗？”
Marie Phillips. She's the author of multiple books, including Gods Behaving Badly. This piece was produced by Bim Adewunmi.
玛丽·菲利普斯。她是多本书的作者，包括《神祇行为恶劣》。这部作品由Bim Adewunmi制作。
["DO YOU SEE WHAT I SEE?" BY HUNTERS & COLLECTORS]
Today's program was produced by Emmanuel Dzotsi and edited by David Kestenbaum. The people who put together today's show include Sean Cole, Phia Bennin, Zoe Chace, Michael Comite, Henry Larson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our executive editor is Emanuele Barry. Special thanks today to Brad Duchaine.
今天的节目由伊曼纽尔·佐特西制作，大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆编辑。制作今天节目的团队包括肖恩·科尔、菲亚·本宁、佐伊·蔡斯、迈克尔·科米特、亨利·拉尔森、凯瑟琳·蕾·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·巴里。今天特别感谢布拉德·杜尚。
By the way, Tig Notaro, who you heard at the top of today's show, has a very funny podcast. It's called Handsome. And you can listen wherever you get your podcasts. You can also check out her tour dates at tignotaro.com. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. You can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free.
顺便说一句，你在节目开头听到的蒂格·诺塔罗，有一个非常有趣的播客。它叫《Handsome》。你可以在任何你获取播客的地方收听。你也可以在tignotaro.com查看她的巡演日期。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。你可以免费流媒体收听我们超过800集的档案。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to my boss, Ira Glass. We're always talking about the election, which voting bloc might sway the vote. Whenever it comes up, he runs into the room yelling, Gen--
《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX分发到公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我的老板，艾拉·格拉斯。我们一直在讨论选举，哪个投票集团可能会左右选举。每当提起时，他就会冲进房间大喊，Gen——
(SCREAMING) Z!
(尖叫) Z!
I'm Tobin Low. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是托宾·洛。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
["DO YOU SEE WHAT I SEE?" BY HUNTERS & COLLECTORS]